Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined for a second time by Dr.
Neil Herbert. We're going to talk about SummerSlam 2026
today, and we're going to refer now and then
to his book with Dr. John Cockburn, who unfortunately
today cannot. Join us Kwave Nation, Professional wrestling, Donald
Trump and the new cynicism. So Dr. Hubbert, welcome
back to the show. It's a very big pleasure
to have you back. I'm,
I'm very happy to be here, you know, for
love of the dissenter, I broke my seven-year boycott
of WWE to watch SummerSlam. Um, HONESTLY, it's not,
it's, I mean, the, the Saudi money did make
it feel kind of. To watch, but honestly, I
just stopped having time to keep up with WWE
once there was a secondary promotion that was more
my taste. So I kind of came into SummerSlam
familiar with most of the wrestlers, uh, most of
the older wrestlers, um, because they were all new
when I was still watching. So I, I know
some of the lore, but also I'm coming in
it a little bit blind. So don't be surprised
if, if I complain about not knowing who the
good guy and the bad guy are in certain
matches, just because it was not always clear.
Yeah, yeah, uh, by the way, and, and we
have to do also, I, I mean, to respect
your own preferences and I also follow away. By
the way, but we also have to do an
episode on the upcoming All In because uh it's
probably going to be a very good show as
always.
I went to the last All In and, uh,
cause I live in Louisiana, so it was just
a short drive to Texas. My wife took me
for a present. It was the best show I'd
ever been to in my life. Um, SO I'm
very excited. I'm gonna watch AEW All in anyway,
as, as I mentioned, uh, before we were recording,
so I'd be happy to talk about it and
hopefully, John. WILL be able to join us too.
I do know John's pet peeve with wrestlers are
good guys who chew gum, because he associates that
with bad guys, and sometimes when there's too many
gum chewers, he just gets, he, he loses, he
loses his Ability to suspend his disbelief. So hopefully,
all in will not be filled with that. But
I remember I messaged him about watching an episode
of AEW and he responded like, Neil, everyone is
just, he's like, they're all heels, they're all chewing
gum. I was like, I'm sorry, I should have,
I should have warned you that, uh, you know,
that's, that, that is, everyone has their pet peeves
for, for me. One of my pet peeves is
whenever the announcer says, for the win, and anytime
the announcer in wrestling says for the win at
a pinfall, it's not gonna be the end of
the match.
Yeah. I mean, you have some things that not
a single one of them curiously is coming to
mind right now, but you have several things that
caller commentators say on wrestling shows that they're giving
away spoilers about the match.
Yeah, it's, I mean,
I mean, when they, when they say particular things,
you already know that the match is not going
to. Went anytime soon.
And that's just because there are patterns in commentary
and that was kind of the, one of the
things I wanted to start off talking about like
the insularity of WWE. So, um, I, I watch
a lot of different promotions. Uh, I, I've got
my CMLL, uh, t-shirt on for, uh, you know,
the, the biggest and oldest, uh, North American wrestling
promotion is in Mexico City. They own Arena Mexico.
And they're also, they formed a loose alliance of
promotions to counter to kind of protect their company
against WWE's encroachments. But WWE it's very interesting. It's
kind of this totalizing entity, and there's always been
a tendency toward that where the only wrestling history
that matters is WWE history. But WWE also has
certain things they do. That it's very clear they
only do because Vince McMahon preferred things to be
done that way. So, you know, like, um, the,
the for the win thing goes back to Vince
McMahon on commentary. Anytime someone says for the win,
it's a signal that the match could end, but
it's not going to end right now because you
don't want to give away the actual pin. Um,
SO, yeah, there's, there's tropes like that, there's, um,
Oh, you, you know, you know one thing, you
know one thing that actually started when Vince was
still there and that really irritates uh my, my,
uh uh uh really irritates me. I mean, the,
the fact that they can't. Call the championship a
belt. I mean, it's a damn belt. What is
something that you put around your waist? Are you
kidding? Are you kidding me? Are you gaslighting me?
It's, and, and you almost never see the wrestlers
in WWE wear the belt around their waist. They
put it on their shoulder. Um, SO it stands
out when you watch another company, and they have
the belt around their waist, or when you watch
like UFC or boxing, and they, they crown the
champion and put it around their waist. So there's
all sorts of little like peccadillos of WWE that
are there. So the first point I wanted to
make is, so, SummerSlam was not an effort to
preach to the unconverted, right? Like, uh, you know,
there, there's a, there's that saying that the preaching
to the choir, that's what, that's what SummerSlam was.
If you already like WWE you're getting a great
show. And the parallel to that to me is
it's, it's kind of like MAGA, not in terms
of like, being, you know, bad or anything, but
like, if you watch how the Trump administration is
functioning. They have stopped speaking to anyone that isn't
already part of the coalition. So you've got in
America right now very high approval ratings for the
war in Iran among Trump supporters, but for literally
60 to 70% of the country, it Very low
approval ratings. So, you know, it goes from with
uh where the Trump administration used to be very
good at managing the crowd, um, they've kind of
now resolved to focus on the crowd that they've
already managed and not worry about the rest. And
that to me was a big thing with WWE.
So like, um, I, I say it's almost like
WWE is engaging in dialogue with itself. The big
thing that stood out to me, and this was
after the Liv Morgan match, which is the first
match on night one, they talk about how great
it was that we were given this moment. And
throughout the show, and throughout both shows, they talk
about how great the moments are. But they never
talk about the matches, right? Like, I, I grew
up in the 80s and 90s. So when I
watched wrestling, the match was the constituent unit of
a pro wrestling show. But for SummerSlam, it's the
moment is the, is the reason you watch the
show, and the match is kind of secondary. And
um, so I, I, I kind of said, it's
serving up red meat to the faithful, but it's
also kind of doubling down on a sort of
stylistic insularity. Do you, did you find the same
thing?
Yeah, no, I I totally agree with you. I'm,
and I mean another thing related to that that
really irritates me is why they don't acknowledge, um,
I mean wrestling from other promotions that they do
not have a partnership with, like, for example, if
it's DNA, OK, that's fine, but if, if it's.
A, if it's, uh, I don't know, a Mexican
promotion that is not AAA, then, and then you
can do it. I, I mean,
would not have killed the show in the main
event of night two to mention that Dean Ambrose
is now John Moxley, and he left the company
since they were talking in the ring about we're
the two that stayed. You know, mentioning that the
other guy left and is now in another company,
I think would have heightened the moment, the moments,
right? If, yeah, I, I completely agree, it's, it's
when you talk about, if we were watching a
different sport, um. They wouldn't refuse to talk about
athletes in other sports or in other promotions or
in other countries.
I mean, because that's a part of their career,
right? I mean, and you, and if you want
to, I, I mean it's even more stupid if
for example, Cody Rhodes came back in 2022 and
they refuse to say that he was where he
was. Between 2016 and 2022, I, I mean, then
the audience who doesn't follow anything outside of WWE,
what are they going to think that he was
basically on hiatus for six years and how does
he come back and he's as good as he
is now? Come on, this, this
is
just
stupid. It's very it's very interesting because when he
came back. If he hadn't left, he would not
be in the position he's in now. He would
still be dashing Cody Rhodes, or wearing a Doctor
Doom mask or whatever he was doing, like, In
the old days in the territory,
no, he, he would be stardust.
He'd be stardust, OK, he'd be stardust, yeah. So
in, in the old days, one of the things
that was natural about wrestling is once a character
or a performer has completed their arc, they go
away, and then you can bring them back and
they're fresh, and frequently after, you know, going away,
they can come back higher on the card because
presumably they've learned a lot. And Cody, I mean,
Cody is really good. Um, I, I like to
make fun of Cody. Because, uh, he cries a
lot when he talks about his dad, you know,
and, you know, as someone whose dad passed away,
I also cry a lot when I talk about
my dad, but I don't put myself on TV
and then intentionally channel that, um, the way that
Cody sometimes does, but, but Cody's a great professional
wrestler. He's got the best entrance in the company.
Like, to me, his theme song, and that's because
it's not a WWE theme song, it's a theme
song he got, um, a band he liked.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's the. That's the other thing
we have to get into the theme songs, because
nowadays, Jesus, are they bad in WWE.
There's a lot of bad entrances, so, um, I
was kind of surprised at how bad some of
the entrances are, because that used to be WWE's
big thing, and I know for WrestleMania, they do
a lot of like pageantry for the entrances, so
I liked Cody coming out as Gile from Street
Fighter 2. That was an ad I saw that
I liked, like there were lots of ads on
the show that I already bought, like, I already
spent $30 on the show. Why, why am I
seeing ads? But, um, when Cody comes out as
the tie in the Street Fighter, I was like,
OK, that's cool. And then Punk came out dressed
as, was he dressed as the Incredible Hulk, or
no, he was, he was dressed as someone from
Minnesota, wasn't he? He was,
uh, I's attire
was a reference to somebody, uh, maybe Vern Goya,
uh, in Minnesota. It could, I, I, I, I
know it was a reference, but I don't remember
what it was a reference to. But yeah, the,
the entrances were, I'll talk about Seth Rollins' entrance
when we get to Seth Rollins' match. Uh, I
was not a fan, short version. I was a
huge fan of Roman Reigns' entrance though. Um, THEY,
they did an excellent job with Roman. I thought
they did an excellent job with Obafemi's entrance. I
having never seen Obafemi before. Yeah,
but you know what, another thing that is irritating
me more and more over time is how some
entrances are so goddamn long in WWE. My God,
why do you need a 5 minute? Entrance for
a single wrestler. Come
on. I, I want to say for the main
event of night two, there were 20 minutes of
entrances and stare downs and announcements and video packages.
Then the match went 30 minutes. Yeah, like, it
was a lot. I, I didn't mind because by
the time I got to the end of night
two, the, the best matches were at the end
of night two, so I was like, OK. But
there were some rough stretches of that show, um,
especially for me, the, the Danhausen stuff is definitely
not for me. Um, THE human money is on
a pole batch. I, I, I'd like, I, I
eventually stopped watching and just kind of waited until
the match was over.
Yeah, you, you know, you know what, the only
reason why I give that a pass, I, I,
I tend to agree with you, but the only
reason I give that a pass is if I
look back. On older pay per views, I mean,
there's always one silly match. There's always one match
that doesn't make much sense, there, it's just for
fun or it's just for a laugh or it's
just for, or, or even it doesn't make any
sense at all, and this, it, it isn't, it
is even a bad match, but it's for me
you always have one like that.
Yeah, for me, the comedy just didn't land. I
don't have a problem. Comedy matches, it's just Dan
Hausen doesn't work for me. Dominic Mysteria though, I
think is great, um, and I've, I've, I've heard
that he is currently not particularly happy with the
way he's being presented since in
one, and I, and I think he's right, I,
I think he's right, by the way. I, I
mean, I think, I think that they're underutilizing him.
He just looks wise, is the most natural heel
in that company and for people who, who might
not. Remember the first talk when I mentioned heel,
that's the, the carny term for a bad guy
and baby face is the carny term for a
good guy. And when I see Dominic Mysterio with
his neck tattoos and all this, like he looks
like, um, the kind of guy in America that,
that sells meth to high school kids behind a
Circle K or a convenience store, right? Like he,
he looks like a scummy dude, and he definitely
looks like the kind of guy you wouldn't want
to take your daughter out on a date. So,
for me, that's a very good thing. But the,
the Danhausen stuff with the, you know, the PC
term is little people, um, with all the little
people coming out in Danhausen masks, and they tell
us one of the little people that's a minihausen
is actually Mini Torito and AAA and blah, blah,
blah, it just, that didn't land for me. Um,
THE, the second point I wanted to make overall
about the show is, and I think this applies
to all of wrestling, but it really applies more
so to WWE is that in the book, we
talk about how to be a wrestling fan, you
have to have 3 different ontologies. There are 3
different realities in a match you track. There's the
reality. The match, uh, the fictional reality, which is
that you're watching a competition where there's a winner
and a loser. Then there's what you're really watching,
which is performers putting on a show, and then
there's what Jody Reisman calls neoKfabe, and we use
that term as well, which is the understanding that
you can't, the neofabe is the combination of both,
and that tends to be a, uh, it tends
to be a hallmark of watching contemporary professional wrestling.
Since the Montreal screw job, WWE has almost completely
eliminated any reference to what we used to call,
what we called the work ontology. Like, there's no
illusion of watching a sporting event when you watch
SummerSlam. Now, that was, you know, and that was
what got me into wrestling. My dad was a
big boxing fan. So when I saw wrestling, it
was like, oh, this is like what my dad
watches, but cooler because they do more stuff. Like,
uh, so for me, the, the, the fictional aspect
of the show is very important. And WWE is
deemphasized. That a great deal.
Yeah, that, that's one of the other things that
irrilates me apart from, oh, you can't say belt.
I mean, now you can say wrestler on WWE,
come on, which is cool because I remember the
first time someone, uh, I think it was in
the CM Punk Pipe Bomb promo in 2011 when
he said, he said the word pro wrestling on
TV and the audience gasped. Like, that's a problem
when we look back on that, right? Like, pro
wrestling is an art form that was beloved for
the better part of a century. And once Vince
McMahon took over, you couldn't call it pro wrestling,
you called it sports entertainment. Well,
yeah, and, and now instead of wrestler, you have
to say superstar.
Star and the WWE universe instead of fans. Like
now that Vince McMahon has been kind of banished
from the promotion, a lot of those no no's
are, are no longer there. And that has helped
the production a great deal. I, I remember the,
when I was writing my dissertation on pro wrestling.
It was right around the time that Dave Meltzer
gave a match in Japan 6.5 stars. And I
had an undergrad who was in a public speaking
class, had to interview, he, he got to, they
asked him to talk to an expert on a
topic of his choosing, and somehow he found me.
And I remember the thing I told him was
that To me, as a wrestling fan, one of
the most destructive things to pro wrestling was that
one person in the American pro wrestling industry for
about twenty-ish years had complete control over what was
on TV, sometimes unopposed, sometimes opposed. So wrestling became
really inseparable from Vince Mc. Man as a promoter's
preferences. And a lot of those preferences are contrary
to what a lot of hardcore wrestling fans like.
And there used to be a thing, if you
read, like, different interviews with people in the business,
that one of Vince McMahon's favorite things to do
is prove to people they're wrong about what they're
like, by doing what they technically wanted him to
do, but doing it badly. And I will say
that didn't feel like it was happening on the
shows I watched from SummerSlam. It, I, I, I
would say there were different challenges associated with it,
but I did not feel like Triple H Paul
Leveck, who is the booker right now, I don't
feel like he was trying to do what the
crowd wanted to prove the crowd shouldn't like what
they like. And that's a big, that's as stupid
as that might sound, that is a big improvement
over how wrestling was promoted in WWE for a
very long time. Um, ANOTHER thing. Uh, WHEN I
talk about moments and things like that, this, this
comes to the commentary. And, uh, so, OK, I,
I, I wrote this down in the main event
of night two. Roman Reigns and Seth Rollins will
stop wrestling and talk to each other. Yeah, they'll
have dialogue, like at a play, and it There's
no, people are gonna laugh at me when I
say this, but there's no subtlety in it. Now,
you might say wrestling is the least subtle art
form there is. Now, I could agree with that,
but even given that, this was a bit obvious.
My old acting teacher, the acting teacher who told
me I needed to be a director because I
wasn't talented, his name was John Dennis, amazing. He
was in Young Frankenstein, if you watch Young Frankenstein,
he's the fat doorman. Uh, THAT, that's like, hello,
like that, that sort of scene. He used to
call acting like we saw with Roman and Seth
indicating, uh, which means that they're performing their feelings
instead of feeling their feelings and letting us see
that they're feeling their feelings. So, and that kind
of gets down to, I feel like in WWE
there is a correct, quote unquote, way to respond
to what you're seeing. And the reason I say
that is because commentary exists to engender that response
in viewers. So, you know, it, it can't be
subtle because with subtlety comes the possibility of different
interpretations. But if you listen to Michael Cole, Michael
Cole is frequently telling us how to feel, and
that's why the moment thing is so important. Because
if the moment is what matters, then the moment
can be explained to you and defined for you,
so that there's a correct and incorrect way to
watch WWD that I don't think is the case
with the way wrestling is presented in many other
promotions. Now, I I will say, you know, CMLL,
they have very strong face heel distinctions, and they're
heel fans, they're heel refs. So it's, you know,
there is a correct and incorrect way to watch
other promotions too, but not to the extent that
WWE is. WWE is very overdetermined in the way
that they want their crowds to react to. And
I think in part that's because they're, they're targeting
children. Um, EVEN though, you know, like, I think
we said this the last time we talked, the
most number of kids that ever watched wrestling was
during the attitude era of WWE, which was decidedly
not kid appropriate, because for the most part, you
know, parents that might be watching will say this,
kids don't want. Watch things that are aimed at
kids. Kids wanna watch things aimed at people that
are older than them so they can feel like
big kids. In my experience, I'm not a parent.
I'm a, I'm a cat dad. I don't know
if y'all could see some cats behind me, but,
uh, uh, we're in my office. So if you
see movement behind me, that's what's going on. But
yeah, like the, that was, that was kind of
the big thing with the commentary that got very
annoying to me is that, you know, I, I
wasn't allowed to just react. I was being told
how to react. Yeah, now, I did enjoy myself
for the most part. I don't, uh, uh, I'm
talking about all the negative because, you know, as
scholars, we, we focus on the critique, right? We
focus on, uh, a grad student would say we
problematize things. Uh, I would say, cause I'm not
a grad student anymore, I would complicate things, right?
That's what, uh, that, that's a better word than
problematize. But, um.
Yeah, and I mean, as intellectuals, we have to
focus on the negative stuff, otherwise we're not taken
seriously, right?
That's very true. That's very true. Like you can't
wear your fandom heart on your sleeve. That's why
I limit it to my shirt, right? Like the,
I finally worked hard enough to get a professor
job so I can wear my Japanese and Mexican
pro wrestling shirts every day. Um, BUT, you know,
on You know, you can't be too enthusiastic. I
remember in grad school, as I, I'm a theater
historian who also does philosophy. That's my philosophy is
my master's degree. And I remember in one of
my classes, one of my classmates from another program,
uh, in English, wanted to write about the musical
Wicked because she loved it. And our professor had
to say, hey, so like, we're, it's really cool
that you love this, but the paper can't be
about your fandom. The paper has to be about
the scholarly reaction to that fandom. So, you know,
I, I, so I, I, I'm gonna pause for
a second and say, uh, things I really liked,
Liv Morgan, she's a star, um, she's, her presentation
as a bad girl champion, wonderful. Um, NOW, she
does attempt to do moves that you see in
Japanese women's promotion, and frequently she does them badly.
But when she avoids those moves, like I think
she, I think it's Rena's head scissors into a
DDT from the ropes, like she, that she did
that in the first match of night one, did
not look good, but everything else looks good. Her
finisher looked good, her facial expressions in particular, like,
I complain a lot during the show that I
don't know who the faces are and I don't
know who the heels are. I knew Liv Morgan
was a heel, and she wanted me to know
that she was a bad girl and she was
not there. So I love Liv Morgan.
Yeah, but, but I, I, I have to say
something on that. I, I mean. I get what
you're saying, but of course since you had been
out of WWE for 7 years and
I've followed, he hasn't been shoved down my throat,
so I'm not tired of it,
yeah, I've followed WWE for that entire period of
time. I have to say that this match, Liv
Morgan versus your Sky. Was the first match that
I could say in terms of in ring was
a good match from Liv Morgan I think I'm
a I'm a I don't, yeah, I, I, I
I I look, if you ask me, tell me
what are your top three Liv Morgan matches. Uh,
I can't. I've only seen one. I mean, I'm
not just in there with the consensus best woman
performer in wrestling right now. So, you know, I
mean my match commentary. She, she did. I'm fairly
confident Liv brought the match down from what it
could be, yeah, but I mean she's. Yo Sky
is really good. So like, I, I didn't mention
that because everyone knows that. Um, THE other, another
good thing I wanted to talk about was, OK,
uh, Nick Aldis's entrance was amazing, uh, British wrestler
coming up to Oasis, just great. Now I know
it was probably expensive for that, but it was
still a wonderful moment, right? It was a great
moment. The match, not so much. Um, ANOTHER thing.
The Bella's and Paige versus Fatal Influence. Now, I've
the match was the match good? No, um, but
also that's because Bree Bella was supposed to be
the, the, the baby face in peril selling, and
she dislocated her shoulder minutes into the match. So
they had to do things pretty early, uh, and
go home early. But I thought the, the women
in Fatal Influence were very impressive, particularly Fallon Henry,
and I'm, I'm told she was a big deal
in NXT. Um, I thought she was very good.
Uh, THERE'S one point where she's walking around outside,
and she just screams at one of the Bella
twins. Uh, SHE calls her a bitch in the
middle of the match, and I was like, oh,
she's gonna have to pay a fine for that
cause the camera definitely picked it up. But she,
those, the, the women in Fatal Influence definitely carried
themselves like they were somebody important. So even though
I've never seen them before, I felt like that
was really cool. Um, THE other big thing, and
then we can go back to pre, pre-prepared comments.
Obafemi, um, I, all I knew about Obafemi was
that he was supposed to be the next big
thing. I left that match with Brock Lesnar, being
like, OK, well he's gonna be the next Roman
Reigns, and that is very clearly what they wanted
to communicate. They successfully did it. The only way
it would have been better would have been if
the match had been shorter, which I know is
a weird thing to complain about. But when I
saw the, the, the pack, the video package giving
me the story, and I saw the entrances, I'm
like, oh, I want Oba to just destroy him
in 4 minutes. Like, I don't want this to
go past. I want Oba just to retire. Brock
Lesnar and be the guy, which I got, it
just, it took a little bit longer to, um,
yeah, it was like 11 minutes instead of 4.
Yeah, and, OK, so this is, this is another
of the things I wanted to mention, um, and
we're gonna, it came up during the Chad Gable
and Penta match, and I mentioned it to you
before we started recording. So for people that are
familiar, the biggest WWE news story of all time
before the Vince McMahon stuff that came out a
couple of years ago was the Chris Benoit murder-suicide.
He's a pro wrestler, a beloved pro wrestler who,
um, due to brain damage, uh, and massive depression.
Uh, BOTH symptoms of his CTE from brain damage,
um, killed himself after murdering his family. And the
WWE did a tribute show to him the day
after he died, uh, the day he, so the
day after he died, which was the day they
found out what happened. There were wellness checks, and
it wasn't until the middle of the show that
it came out that Chris Benoit had been the
murderer. So they made a promise the next show,
which was smackdown that week. To never mention Chris
Benoit again on WWET TV because they felt so
bad that they lionized a murderer, and I get
that, um. In the Chad Gable match, um, Chad
Gable did one of Chris Benoit's signature moves, and
the reason it stands out is this is the
move that is believed to have caused a lot
of the brain damage. It's called a swan dive
headbutt. He, he spreads his arms, jumps off the
top rope, and kind of goes horizontal, heads right
here, and then slams his head into the person's
body. It's a very alarming move once we learned
about brain damage and things like that. And when
he did this, The announcer screamed, vintage Chad Gable.
And there's a, a discourse in theater and performance
studies that John and I are both big fans
of. I believe, I believe we cite it in
our book, um, and it's a, it's a paper
or series of books by Odai Johnson. He is,
I believe, a professor emeritus at University of Washington
in Seattle. And he talks about the, uh, Act
of remembering to forget things, and he puts that
in context of the first instance of theatrical censorship,
which is uh the performance of Frinicus's play, The
Capture of Mileus in ancient Athens, which was about
an Athenian colony that was conquered and razed to
the ground, and Athens did not. Send its armies
to support them. So Phrinius wrote a play about
the shame of Athens not doing that. And the,
I believe it won the festival. It was his
first win, but the, uh, they called together the,
uh, the people to vote, and they fined Prinius
for making them remember something unpresent. And banished the
play. No one could ever do it again because
it would bring up unpleasant memories. And uh Oda
compares that to the concept of ostracism, where you
take a vote, you expel someone, you reduce their
house to rubble, so that everyone sees the house
as a reminder to forget. And the problem with
the Chris Benoit diving headbutt is that we kind
of have that situation for anyone with a sense
of wrestling history, that move is not vintage Chad
Gable, it's vintage Chris Benoit, and it very much
takes me out of the match. Now, that's not
the only move like that. Shawn Michaels, who's considered
one of the, the best American pro wrestlers in
WWE history, He was one of the first people
to do Chris Benoit's finisher move finishing move afterwards,
the crippler crossface, which is a submission hold. Even
then, it was something that just, I think it's
gonna take a couple more decades before people can
take those signature moves and get them outside the
context of Of that tragedy. So for me, that,
that sort of, I think Chris Benoit's moves being
done are, are sort of like this reminder to
forget about Chris Benoit. But the thing about remembering
to forget is you're not really forgetting. Um, IN
fact, you're doing the opposite of forgetting, right? You
are being crystal clear on what you are not
supposed to remember, which requires you to remember it.
So that, that sort of tension there, uh, was
a big problem.
And, and, and by the way, when it comes
to that move specifically, because what came to my
mind when that happened during the match, apart from
what you said was, I mean, should people still
be doing this move because of what we know
now?
Well, and it's not just Chris Benoit, like, if
you look at the person Chris Benoit idolized, the
dynamite kid. Dynamite kids in a wheelchair. He did,
he, he wrestled a style that was so violent,
and he put so much muscle on such a
small body because he was also undersized like Chris
Benoit, he was 5'8, 59. He, he was not
able to maintain his health doing that style of
wrestling. It's the same thing. Maybe there are some
moves that we shouldn't do, which, which kind of
brings me to my next point, which is that
in WWE, uh, the biggest marks are the wrestlers.
Now, for people that don't know wrestling history, mark
is the old school term for people that are
being tricked to believe wrestling is real. Now, the
people The audience no longer believe wrestling is real.
Um, THE people that are wrestling in WWE are
often the ones who, who think what they're doing
matters more than it does, particularly in terms of
labor conditions, which we talked about in the book.
Um, THERE are, if you follow wrestling journalism, there
are many people in WWE who have been offered
more money to go to other promotions, but they
choose to go to WWE because they grew up
as WWE fans. And they're led to believe that
a WrestleMania moment is more important than financial security.
To the point right now that there are people
that are being, having their contracts renegotiated for less
money. Many of them are choosing to stay with
like half salary just to stay in WWE. Now,
we're about to see some of the people who
are like, no, we're gonna go make more money
in AEW and you can fire me. Uh, THE
New Day in particular, about to. Jump over to
AEW, but to me, like, a lot of the
people in WWE, I, I think it's indisputable that
they would get a bigger opportunity to have better
matches in other promotions, whether that's TNA, even NXT,
right? Like NXT is the feeder promotion, AAA, uh,
those are the WWE affiliates, as well as the
AEW CMLL, New Japan Stardom affiliates. Um, I, I
think that, you know, WWE is really doubling down
on hiring old fans, so that they can make
sure that they're not paying as much and that
they don't have to improve labor conditions. Now, we
say that, and like in the book, we talk
about how, you know, maybe the only thing we
can hope for is a good billionaire instead of
an evil billionaire running a company. But at, at
the same time though, I, I mean, I don't
think it's unreasonable to talk about unionization. IN wrestling.
I don't think it's unreasonable to talk about forcing
the government once there, there's a government change in
the United States to renegotiate or look at the
idea that WWE and, and AEWE wrestlers are independent
contractors. Now, in AEW they actually are cause they
can take bookings elsewhere, um, as long as they're
not booked already, but in WWE you cannot get
booked anywhere else. So they are in no way
fitting the legal definition of an independent contractor. Uh,
THEY don't have health insurance, they have to buy
it themselves, they don't have X, Y, and Z.
And I think that that's, uh, you know, one
of the reasons that can continue is people are
so grateful to be in their dream job that
they're willing to do it. Now, I will say
this, I'm also in my dream job. I took
a massive pay cut to go to my dream
job from a charter school teaching high school, and
so I'm a big mark too, like, I'm, I'm
in no position to like criticize wrestlers for being
marks when I'm the biggest mark for academia there
is. Um, BUT it still stood out that these
people that we're watching perform are at least having
the time of their lives, or when the matches
are obviously too short, pissed off that they're not
having the time of their lives. Yeah.
No, I, I agree as well with that point.
So I mean, should we go, let's go match
by match. Yeah, those are, those are my big
overarching points. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I've got, I've
got my notes. Um, SO yeah, the first match
is Liv Morgan versus EO Sky. Um, THE first
thing I noticed is that. Uh, Liv Morgan is
really not as good at hitting people and making
it look real as Eyo Sky is. For people
that might not be familiar, Eyo Sky is consensus
considered one of the best women's wrestlers on Earth,
if not the best women's wrestler on Earth. Previously,
it was Oka, who was Kana in Japan, and
I, I, I still think Oska is unbelievable. Anytime
I see her, I, she's probably my favorite. Women's
wrestler, I got to see her live in NXT
in 2017, 1 of the best shows of my
life, for 2016. I saw it in 2016, so
much fun, so awesome. So I, I was excited
to finally see EO Sky, and I liked the
match. Um, THE, the big thing is though, Having
been to stadium shows, stadium shows are awesome if
you're in the crowd live, but they aren't usually
mked well for TV, and that was a consistent
thing I noticed with SummerSlam, and I suspect we're
gonna notice it at all in when we talk
about that as well too, is that the the
TV cameras, it, it, the crowd sounds less excited
than they actually are. Like we could see the
crowd cheering. But because the building is so large,
you don't hear the crowd getting involved the way
you would in a smaller building. Yeah, um, I
thought, and we, we kind of already talked about
this, um, it's very clear that the WWE thinks
Liv Morgan is one of their biggest stars. Um,
TO me, that's the one thing I knew about
because I've seen, even though I don't watch WWE,
I saw the Dominic Mysterio Liv Morgan kiss. I
see the, the lots of pictures of Liv Morgan
wearing Daddy Dom shirts and things like that. So
I, I, yeah, I can tell they're really invested
in her. And, you know, you, you said she's
usually not that good of a wrestler. They did
put her in with the best wrestler. In the
world, she had a good match. Um, I was,
I was left thinking like I'd like to see
more of Liv Morgan. I'm, I might be in
the minority because I don't watch regularly, but I,
I liked that match, um, particularly when Liv Morgan
did the code breaker, one of Chris Jericho's old
moves from the top rope. I, I remember I
yelled, I was like, Oh, I thought she killed
Yo. So that was a fun match to me.
What did you think?
Uh, I, I mean, I have two things to
say. I, I, I mean, and, and actually these
are two things that apply not just to Liv
Morgan but also to, uh, the WWE more generally.
I mean, one of them is I mean, at
this point I'm getting sick and tired of all
of these hills that win matches just because of
outside interference. I mean, it's just, why is it
that we can't have a hill that is just
so strong. He or she can win them matches
without someone interfering. I mean, why can't you have
a strong heel? Why do all heels have to
be weaker than their baby baby baby face versions?
And why do they have to always play their
I mean, why can't you have just a heel
that is philosophically opposed to the baby face and
doesn't play dirty or doesn't need people from their
group to interfere with the match for them to
win. I mean, well,
historically it's because if the heel cannot out wrestle
the baby face, the heel is actually the baby
face. That's how territorial wrestling presented it. But I
think you can see models of how to make
what you're talking about work. Um, SOMEONE like MJF
in AEW, MJF loves to cheat, and the tragedy
of MJF is that he could win without cheating,
and he proves that over and over again, but
he's so despicable. He takes shortcuts, and I didn't
see a heel that did that. WWE, um, I,
I think that that would be something that that
version of heal is a time-tested heel. The person
who's despicable because he chooses to do evil, uh,
when he's perfectly capable of doing good, right? So
for me, um, you know, the, when you have
too much outside interference, it does get kind of
boring because You know, it's at that point, it's
like, why are there, why is the promotion so
incompetent? It can't, cause in the NBA, right? No
one from a third team runs on the court
and, and helps, uh, someone block a shot. If
that happened, things would be very, very, uh, different.
There'd be fines, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So,
in wrestling, you'd think the same thing. And, and
I know, uh, there are some promotions that have
titles where you They, uh, don't allow outside interference,
and if there is outside interference, both people, the
person interfered on and the person interfering are in
storyline fired. So that's why no one will do
it because they, they know they can't get away
with it. I would like to see something like
that, but yeah, like, from what I saw in
Live with EO Sky, I, I would have been
fine with Liv just taking a few shortcuts, um,
or, or, you know, like injuring. Yo's arm or
something like that and then ruthlessly attacking it and
taking a shortcut like that, yeah, because in hiring
a girl to come out and distract and blah
blah blah blah blah, yeah,
because this is something that really pissed me off
during Roman reign's reign. I mean, I mean, no,
not that he's 1300. Something they because uh after
a certain point, particularly when Jay Uso and Jimmy
Uso joined him, it was match after match after
match after match, him always winning because of interference.
I mean, and it's tiring. I mean, is he
strong or is he not strong?
Come on. And he also didn't have many. Matches
during that run because he's a part-time wrestler, um,
which, you know, it is what it is, but
I, I don't think the 1500 day reign or
however many days it is, is impressive when he'd
go 100 days between matches, right? Like Bruno San
Martino wrestled every week. Uh, THAT was Athena in
Ring of Honor wrestles almost every week. So it's,
it's a very different achievement than Roman
Reigns. By the way, the same thing applies to
Liv Morgan during her current reign because she's, she
went for, right,
yeah,
since WrestleMania, it was like a 90 day, uh,
non-defense championship.
I mean, that is the problem when, when your,
your champion is champion because she's good in skits
and not good in the ring. So, you know,
like, on the one hand, Yeah, it's annoying that
on a wrestling show, the, the, the champion doesn't
wrestle, but it's a different problem when maybe it's
best that the champion doesn't wrestle, right? Like, at
that point, it's like, oh, well, maybe. Maybe we
should reevaluate.
No, no, no, because that's another thing that sort
of irritates me nowadays in WWE. I mean, now
it's pervasive, this idea that, oh my God, certain
big names shouldn't be overexposed, otherwise people will get
tired of them. I mean, go back to the
attitude error, Stone Cold, The Rock and Undertaker every
single. Single show they were there, and then anyone
ever get tired of them. I mean, come on,
come on. The, the only time I think you
should not overexpose someone is when you're dealing with
like a giant or a special attraction, like, because
Andre the Giant, the way they protected Andre in
the territory days is he would be brought in
for one big match, and that was when you
saw Andre the Giant, because if you see him
every week, you might notice that some of the
tall guys are actually as tall as Andre. So
you had to do it like that. But for
the most part, if, if your champion gets over
by just being a badass wrestler, then having them
wrestle is a really good thing. You, it's the
opposite of overexposing them. You're seeing them perform their
strengths. So, you know, for Liv, I'm guessing since
what you're saying is she's not great in the
ring, like they're probably maximizing her minutes by not
making you watch her wrestle except once every 100
days.
Yeah, and that's why, and this is. Sort of
post SummerSlam. That's why I'm hoping that now they're
going to set up a feud between Becky Lynch
and Stephanie Wacker to elevate Wacker even further. I
hope that happens and then I hope that Wacker
just takes the title of Liv Morgan. I mean,
because I'm just tired of Liv Morgan
talking about WWE wrestlers being marked. Stephanie Vaker is
one who was offered much more money to go
to WWE. After her match with Mercedes Monet, but,
uh, she, she was offered more money to go
to AEW, but she grew up watching WWE in
Chile. I believe she's Chilean, right? So she wanted
to go where she watched wrestling as a kid.
So, you know, like, good for her. She's living
out her dream. Um, CONTRAST that with someone like
Blake Monroe who, as best I can see, is
only doing internet shows eating chicken wings and not
wrestling. She went from being one of the best,
my God, that. That's another thing. I don't know
why WWE does so much of this of, oh,
moving someone from NXT to the main roster and
then and then keep hyping them, hyping them, hyping
them, but then it takes like weeks or months
to fight for them to finally have a match
on the main roster. I mean, what the heck?
When Blake Monroe was Mariah May, she was probably
Favorite women's wrestler in AEW. I thought she was
terrific. Um, AND I really hope WWE fans get
to see what she can do because she's, she's
wonderful in the ring. She's a great actor too,
on top of that. Um, BUT, you know, she's
living her dream. She's another one. You go back,
look at her Twitter account from 1516 years ago.
She's live tweeting Monday Night Raw and pay per
views and stuff. So she's another one. Just she's
living out her dream. Good for her. Let's, let's
switch gears now and talk about the, um,
The yeah, the, yeah, the, theos, yeah, it
was plus Jacob Fatu against LA Knight, Royce Keys,
and Solo Sokoa,
right? Yes,
um, I don't, not not to sound like the
mom on Arrested Development, I don't care for the
Uos. Uh, I'm not a fan of Jay. I'm
not a fan of the Yeat man, I'm, I'm
not a fan of. Honestly, I, the, the person
I thought stood out in that match was Jacob
Batu. Um, I thought he was really good. Um,
I noticed that there were Gears of War themed
entrances for, for this, so they incorporated the ads,
like, we see. So for people who don't know,
between every match, you see at least 3 or
4 ads. Then the entrances are often ads as
well with a tie-in to one of the sponsoring
products. So some people came out with a Gears
of War themed, uh, entrance cause E-Day is coming,
the, the next Gears of War game. And, uh,
so they found a way to incorporate that. But
that, that match, um, It was very interesting. The
first thing I wrote, cause Jay Uso started the
match is Jay Uso is no Jerry Lawler when
it comes to punches. His punches looked awful, um,
but I didn't have a lot to say about
the match just because I, I didn't think it
was particularly interesting. I didn't know who the good
guys and the bad guys were. I assumed the
Usos were good guys because they're with Roman, but
now my friends in my wrestling group chat that
we texted about, like, oh no, dude, they're the
heels, like, what? But they were, but he was
screaming ye and doing all this stuff for the
crowd. So again, the, the face heel distinction seemed
incoherent. I thought that Royce Keys. IS a big
downgrade in AA from when he was Powerhouse Hobbs.
It's another thing where I know the WWE wants
to own people's names, but, you know, the man's
in his 40s, he, they signed him because he
was a really standout wrestler and big man who
looked perfect for WWE, but then they stripped him
of all the things that made them want to
sign him. So that, that was Peculiar. Um, I
did think that Jacob Fatu felt very special, and
LA Knight, his finishing move looked awesome. Um, AND
LA Knight seemed to be the biggest good guy
in the building, uh, in night one. So I'm,
I'm not sure, is he gonna be pushed to
the main event? Are they talking about that? What
do you think?
I mean, for someone who's been following WWE this
entire time, it's just hilarious that you say that
because he's been over for at least 2 years,
but Triple H refuses to push him. So I
don't think that's going to happen. I don't think
that's going to happen. I mean, there are certain
guys that I don't know exactly why. I don't
know exactly why, but. JUST refuses to push them.
I mean, it's very interesting because like, it seemed
to me that of the people with like an
organic connection with the crowd so far, he's the
big one. HE might not have been the best
person in the ring. There was some stuff that,
you know, wasn't awesome when he was in there,
but he was fine, you know, and it's not
like he's in a promotion where you have to
be the best in ring. Performer on earth, right?
There's no Kurt Angle in WWE anymore setting the
bar that high in the main event. They're producing
a different style. There's nothing about LA Knight that
wouldn't work with the WWE Main Event style. Um,
IT'S, you know, he would be fine, and I
thought that it was, it was very obvious the
crowd adored him. So to me, it's like, well,
this is gonna be the next big baby face.
Apparently not. That's. It is what it is, but,
you know, I see these interviews with Triple H
where he says like, oh, people who complain about
who's in the main event, you've got to take
their spot. You've got to get over on your
own. Well, it looks like LA Knight got over
on his own, and he's curtain jerking, right? He's
in the second match. Um, SO that's all I
have to say about that one. WHAT do you
think of Gunther and Nick Aldis?
Uh, I mean, Gunther and Nick Aldi. I, I,
I mean, the, the thing about. IS that they're
sort of they turned him into a guy who's
supposedly be who supposedly now is the one who's
always there to end careers. I mean yeah, it's
the career killer. I mean the end of the,
or supposedly end of the career of Goldberg, John
Cena, AJ Stiles, and now Nick Aldis. I mean,
I guess. If they want to give just Nick,
if they wanted to give just Nic Aldis his
flowers and oh, OK, you can have a match
in a pay per view, I mean they call
it PLEs now, but whatever in a pay per
view, in the WWE pay per view, yeah, we're
going to give you a match. I mean, so.
I guess that's cute in a way, but, uh,
the, the thing about it
was ringside, right? So he did get the big
WWE PLE moment in front of his wife, who's,
you know, uh, the, the very famous modern wrestler
Mickey James, very accomplished women's wrestler, and his son.
So like, and they came in the ring afterwards
and hugged him. Like I thought that was really
cool, and I will say I did. Listen to
the Wrestling Observer reviews of these shows after I
watched them, and that was the consensus that they're
primarily interested in Nick Aldis as a GM. But
since he is a big, since he is a
big part of their show, they wanted to honor
him and give him that big moment, um, because
the, the reality is, Nick Aldi is good. He's
not great in the way that Gunther is great,
in the way that Roman Reigns is great, in
the way that others, so there's a limit for
him as an in-ring performer in WWE that would
not be there as a GM, and I've been
told he's excellent as a GM. He, so, you
know, I, I was, I was very happy to
see that. I, I've watched Nick Aldis before. I've
watched him in the NWA.
Yeah, but the only thing about Gunter is that
it seems like they don't have any specific, any
proper direction for him. I, I, I, I mean,
because he wasn't having, first of all, he didn't
even have a match at WrestleMania. I mean, he,
he had just ended John Cena, John Cena's and
AJ Sta's careers and. He didn't have a match
on WrestleMania. I mean, that's insane. Uh, HOW come
you went the career of the, uh, of what
they're calling the goat of WWE John Cena and
you don't have a match on WrestleMania,
a champion, right? You'd think he'd be one of
the top champions if he's ending all of these
legendary people's careers like that. That seems like it
would be the the logical thing. I, I will
say Gunther is one of the few guys that's
really good in ring that I would not recommend
jumping to a different promotion. He really stands out
in WWE. Now, if he were to jump, it
would be because of bad creative, but, you know,
unlike a lot of guys in WWE, he's found
his niche in that company. He's got a role.
It's just The creative that's a problem. Um, FOR
most guys like Sammy Zane, Kevin Owens, uh, Chad
Gable, I think all of them would have benefited
from jumping to a different promotion, like Cody did
than being brought back at a higher level. Um,
BUT Gunther, I think he's the one that broke
that curse. Now, I, I also wanna say, I
did prefer him as Walter. I thought his WWE
NXT stuff as Walter was unbelievable, and that Volter
versus, uh, Ilya Dragonov stuff might be the best
matches in WWE history. So, you know, even though
they were under the NXT UK banner, um, I,
I was still very impressed, and I thought Volter
versus, uh, the bruiserweight back when they were in
NXT was at that time the best match I've
seen under the WWE banner. Um, I thought it
was better than everything until they did Adam Cole
versus Johnny Gargano, which is my personal pick for
best WWEE match I've ever seen. So, but yeah,
I enjoyed the Gunther thing. I a thing I
noticed about this stylistically is that the WWE is,
is the pace of their matches is much slower
than other promotions, and that is intentional, um. I
know that if you talk to uh people that
are in the WWE will frequently talk about doing
things the right way and the wrong way, and
the WWE way that that is right is you
slow down to give the moment, the moments, time
to breathe. Um, I found myself bored, uh, sometimes.
I, I think that most matches could have been.
20% shorter, the ones that were long at least,
and worked at least 20% faster. Um, AND they
all would have been better, like, especially the main
event of night two. Like if that had just
been faster, um, and a little bit shorter, I
think, I think the match would have been much
better. Um, uh, SAME goes for, we'll. Talk about
punk and Cody later. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, because the thing I agree with you,
and the thing is, yeah, if you're going to
want to have those break moments, so to speak,
and then now and then wrestlers talking to each
other or wrestlers talking to the camera. I mean,
that makes much more sense if you're doing a
movie and not a wrestling match. I mean, to,
to have the sort of dialogue and those dramatic
pauses during
the
fight
and dialogue, um, and, and the thing I see
on, on Twitter for, for fans of WWE, they
talk about things being cinema. I, when I watch
wrestling, I don't wanna watch cinema. I wanna watch
wrestling. Um, YOU know, when I wanna watch cinema,
I go to the movies, and, you know, I
don't go to the movies very often because it's
very expensive, which I also hear WWE live events
are now. Um, SO maybe they're similar in that
way, but, but yeah, I don't want the dialogue
during the match. I'm fine with, with the monologues,
with the exchanges backstage, but If you're gonna stop
competing in the match and be like, oh baba,
uh, they left, we're here, blah blah, it's like,
come on. Now, there was an instance of talking
I liked in the, uh, Chad Gable Pina match
when Pinta apologized before kicking the hell out of
Chad Gable's head. I was like, OK, that, that's
fine, and cause it's a callback to, to me
at least, to the Shawn Michaels Ric Flair retirement
match where Shawn Michaels apologizes to Rick before ending
his career. Um, I was like, OK, I liked
that callback, but, but that's because it was a
line. It wasn't dialogue going back and forth while
they just stood there. Um, YEAH, we've already, we've
already kind of talked about Bella's and Paige versus
Fatal Influence with Bree Bella getting injured a couple
of minutes in. Um, AT the, at the beginning
of the match, I wrote that I think it's
gonna be pretty because until she got injured, I
thought Bree was pretty good as the, the baby
face getting beat down. Um, IT'S very clear, uh,
I've read different things that her husband is her
coach, and her husband is possibly the greatest wrestler
of all time. So, you know, it's like she's
gonna be, you know, as long as, if, if
he's her trainer right now, she's gonna be the
strongest in that match cause I love Soraya. I
thought Soraya's comeback or page, uh, in AEW was
very moving. I thought her entrance music was great.
But, but Soraya slash Paige is not known for
being a good wrestler. She was a, she was
the first goth girl that they brought into WWE
in the 2000s. That was a lot of people's
first crush, and, uh, especially younger men, and she's
beautiful. She's one of the most beautiful people on
the planet, but when you watch Paige, Her thing
is not the end ring. Her thing is the
presentation, the appearance. And I also, here's the other
thing, I discovered I had nostalgia for Nikki Bella.
I never would have dreamed I had nostalgia for
Nikki Bella, but when she got in there, I'm
like, OK, Nikki, all right, like, you know, did
I watch Total Divas? No. Um, BUT a lot
of my women friends did. And Nikki Bella did
a lot of work mainstreaming women's wrestling that she
doesn't get enough credit for. So when she got
in with her, her, like her hair set up,
she looks kind of, I'm like, OK, Nikki, all
right, like this is, this is kind of cool.
So I was pleasantly surprised to learn that I
missed Nikki Bella and Bree Bella, um, and, and
that I had a little bit of nostalgia for
that. Um, SO yeah, um, the other, I,
I mean, the, the only thing I'm going, uh,
I have to say is that I honestly think
that Fallon Henley should be the front woman instead
of JC Jane.
I thought she was better than JC Jane. I
thought JC Jane was. Very good, but I thought
Fallon Henry really stood out in terms of the
way she carried herself. Like, she carried herself like
she was somebody I should care about in a
way that the other two women didn't. Like, it's,
it's like Fallon Henry felt like a more complete
pro wrestler to me. Uh, BUT that's just going
off of appearances, right? Like, so maybe she's just
better at emoting and physicality, uh, but I, I
thought she was the standout, not JC Jane, although
I did like JC Jane a lot. I thought
the third woman in Fatal Hinge, Laney Reed. I
thought Laney Reed was the weakest of those three,
but I left that match wanting to see all
three of them more. Um, I think the young
women in WWE are really promising. Uh, FOR the
most part, they're the ones that stand out, not
the young men that I saw coming out of
NXT. Um, SO, OK, let's talk Rhodes versus Punk.
What do you think of Rhodes versus Punk?
Um, I'm, I, I'm, I mean it, I, I
think that in ring, it was quite good. Uh,
IT was the best match of the first night
except for maybe the Sky match.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I was
also thinking about the Obafemi versus Brock Lesnar, but
that, that one was not so much in terms
of being a really technical match. It was just
that, uh, it was just for the purpose that
the match had to serve. It, it was really
good.
I mean that crown that match was about crowning
Obafemi as the present and Brock Lesnar as the
past, and it accomplished that. It could have done
it quicker. You know, the thing about Cody and
Punk was, um, It was sloppy. Like, a lot
of the time it was slop, like punk through
did the worst moon salt I may have ever
seen.
Uh, YEAH, I, I, I, I almost, I almost
forgot about that one. Yeah. I,
I laughed out loud when he, when he landed
and looked at the camera and was like, uh.
You know, I, I thought that was funny, but
I don't know, they, they worked a very 1980s
slow style, and I just did not want to
see a match that slow at that point in
the show. Um, Cody Rhodes, I don't think gets
his flowers enough at how good he is in
ring. Um, I know punk is older, and, um,
I will say it is difficult for me to
watch punk in WWE after listening to all of
the interviews he did for a decade about how
WWE destroyed his love for pro wrestling and almost
killed him with. Diagnosed staph infections and MRSA. So
for me, it's sort of like, man, CM Punk
is like a complete sellout and hypocrite for going
back there. Um, AND that, that kind of defined
the match a bit. Like, I don't necessarily want
to see him back in AEW, but it feels
like For all the shit he talked about WWE
and this and that, it's, it's like him going
back was, it, it, it, it just doesn't feel
right for me as a fan. But, um, yeah,
yeah, and, and also when it, I was going
to say because you mentioned how the match was
so slow. I think that for the kind of
build that they have in terms of their bodies,
I mean, I think that they should do a
faster match, a faster.
I mean, they're not muscle bound like Obafemi and
Brock, so they can maintain a faster pace, but
with punk being like 48, 49. That might be
the fastest he can go, um, and that's OK.
Like, I, I, yeah, but Cody can certainly kick
it up a notch. And, you know, when you've
got a wrestler who's physically limited and a wrestler
who isn't, typically the wrestler who isn't can provide
the illusion of movement. That's what Kevin Nash used
to call it. He's like, oh, I loved working
with Sean cause I could just stand there and
he moved so much, it looked like. I was
moving and no one noticed that I was just
standing still. You could do the same thing with
that because Cody is very good. And the, you
know, as much as I like to, to goof
on Cody Rhodes, he has a great entrance. He's
a great performer. Um, YOU know, I hear they
want to turn him heel and he doesn't want
that because that's why he left AEWs. They wanted
to turn him heel, so I don't know how
that's gonna go, but Cody Rhodes is great. Uh,
I, I loved him in AEW. I thought it
was very dumb when he did that stipulation where
he could never be world champion cause he obviously
should have been, um, cause he's an exceptional performer,
and, uh, you know, I'm glad he's getting his,
his flowers in WWE cause he's very, very good.
Um, AND he, he deserves to be given like
that. He, he earned, he didn't deserve it, he
earned it, is the way that, that I would
say, like he's a very good performer. He, he
should be in the main events. Um, WHAT about
hell in a cell? Uh, I,
I, I mean, the, the only negative thing that
I have to say about the hell in a
cell match is that it didn't really feel like
a hell in a cell match. I, I mean,
I, I, I mean, it was almost, uh, as
if the cell was not. There, I mean, they
could have done, they could have done 98% the
same match without the cell. They barely used the
cell.
I mean, it didn't feel like a hell in
a cell match. They didn't integrate the cell into
the structure of the match. It would have been
better as a straight match to me, um, because
the cell kind of took the cell took away
from the match because if it wasn't a hell
in a cell, they could have gone shorter. I
think that's why they had to go 12 minutes.
Like we can't have a hell in a cell
match end in 5 minutes. Yeah, but a couple
of things I noticed, production wise, the sound in
the cell was very good. They, they miked that
cell and the ring very well for that. Um,
THE other thing is, Lesnar looked both old and
sad. Uh, HE turned purple, like the, like a
grape. Uh, DURING the match, cause, you know, he
was out of breath, and, um, uh,
uh, uh, that, that's been happening for a while
now, actually. I mean, him turning red, purple,
yeah. It was weird, um, I, but, but I
haven't, you know, I haven't watched Brock in a
long time, so I wasn't aware of the, the
redness thing. Um, SO the other thing I noticed
is when, when Brock pulled up the ring, uh,
pad and exposed the boards and did a tombstone.
Yeah, that would have been so much more impactful
if the Undertaker had just retired after he lost
to Brock. At WrestleMania and didn't come back.
Yeah, because, because that was like 12 years ago
or
so. Exactly. If that had been the end of
The Undertaker, then Brock, the pulling out the Undertaker's
finisher, you know, they, they talk about in the
next thing I wrote is Michael Cole said, what
a memory we've been given tonight. Well, it would
have been a better memory if, you know, the,
the past story that was being referenced had made
sense because it it.
And you know what, it, it would have been
a better memory also if Brock Lesnar didn't decide
to go off script during WrestleMania and made as
if he had to retiring then,
yeah, yeah, I mean, I, I feel like if
you're gonna do the, the take off your gloves,
leave your boots in the, you kind of got
to retire, you know, you, but, you know, it
is what it is. Um, I, I get that.
And, you know, I do have a lot of
happy memories of watching Brock, and uh I was
left thinking, oh, I would like to see Obafemi
in there with someone who's a really good wrestler
to see what he can do in a technical
match because, you know, the thing about Cody as
a top guy is Cody Rhodes can both emote
in the, in the promos and have good matches.
But since I've only seen Obafemi once, uh, I
don't know how good he is. How good is
he in the ring?
No, I think he's great. I mean, he, he
has had some great matches in NXT before getting
called up, and I think that his, his trilogy
of matches with Brock Lesnar, I mean, in that
kind of style of two monsters clashing with each
other, have have also been great, so I mean
I, I don't have anything, I don't think I
have anything. Negative to say about Obafemi and and
and I mean when it comes to matches being
like as we sometimes say, a wrestling clinic or
just being, I mean, meat on meat or something
like that. I mean, I don't have anything against
the second type of match. They're fun. I mean
if they're doing, if they're done right, they're fun
as well.
The I know in AEW when Powerhouse Hobbs, now
Royce Keys, would wrestle other big guys, the crowd
would just scream meet over and over again as
they hit each other. And you know, I don't
want to see every match like that, but sometimes
you just want to see two big guys hit
each other, and it's fun. Another thing, um, so
I teach a lot of international students at the
HBCU. I'm a professor at rambling. And a lot
of my international students come from Africa. So to
me, having the next big baby face be coming
from the developing world is a huge thing, I
think. And, uh, a lot of my international students
that like wrestling love WWE. So I think that
in terms of global growth and things like that,
getting 100% behind. Uh, AN African baby face is
really cool because you've got, I, the, the thing
I noticed other than Obafemi, none of the, the
male wrestlers except for Javon Evans on the show
were black. Am I forgetting anyone? Were there any
other people of color that were men? Because we
had a lot of Samoans, we had a lot
of Samoans, but, you know, the, I think in
terms of African American or African men, we only,
there was a Trick Williams on night two, right?
Trick, trick.
Oh, that's what I, yeah, Trick Williams. OK, cool.
Yeah, so we have 3, and of those, I
thought the only one who really stood out was,
uh, was Obafemi. Um, SO for me, I think
getting behind the main event black good guy is
a really good thing because You know, like, representation,
especially in an American focused business is very important.
And for the developing world to have this aspirational
figure presented as like a godlike, uh, performer, I
think it's gonna be really cool. It's something you
don't see a lot. I mean, the only other
African wrestlers I can name off the top of
my head is like Nigeria's Power Ui. And the,
the thing about Paruzzi is he was not good,
uh, you know, he was very big, but he
wasn't particularly good. So having someone coming up that's,
that's being presented in this beautiful way, uh, shown
as like this, the epitome of masculinity, and he
comes from the developing world, I think that's a
really good look and, uh, something I like.
I, I agree. Yeah, so, let's move on to
night two.
So for night two, it starts with Finn Ballard
versus Sammy Zane. Then Nick Aldis comes out and
adds Gunther and Kevin Owens to the match. Um,
AND this is the match where I noted, all
three guys that weren't Gunther probably would have benefited
from jumping ship to a different promotion and coming
back after a couple of years. Um, I think
I've never been a Finn Ballard fan. Um, EVEN
though I watched New Japan, Prince Devitt was not,
I never got into him as a heavyweight. I
thought he was a good junior weight, but in
Japan, if you're a junior heavyweight, there's a limit
to how good you can be. And Finn Ballard,
the Bullet Club back then was him and, uh,
Carl Anderson, and, uh, God, the other guy, um,
uh, I, I unfortunately didn't watch that part of
his career,
so it wasn't the good brothers are who they
wrestle as in the, in the United States. They
were the, uh, the club in WWE when they
hung out with AJ. So that era of Bullet
Club was not my favorite. So I'm not a
huge Finn Ballard fan. I think he's got a,
a million dollar look in terms of his presentation.
But it's very obvious he has a ceiling in
WWE because of his size, and if he had
gone somewhere else and proven that he deserved that,
that, that shot, I think it could have helped.
But at the
same time I, I, I think he was also
very unlucky because back in 2016. I think it
was 2016 when he won the the Universal championship
the first universal champion.
Yeah, he was the first universal champion, but on
the same match, he got a huge injury, yeah,
like a massive injury, and I remember next week
Kevin Owens came out and said, I'm the longest
reigning universal champion of all time. And I was
like, oh, it's such a good, that's such a
good heel move. So I wasn't a big fan
of Prince David. Um, I love Sammy Zane. I
love Kevin Owens. I think both of them are
incredibly talented, and I know both of them are
probably WWE lifers because they grew up. Kevin Owens
learned to speak English watching Monday Night Raw. He
thought Slobberdocker was a The old term in English
that everyone used, so, um, and apparently he got
made fun of for that when he came to
America. So I love those guys. I, I think
they're great. Um, I think Kevin, yeah,
the, the only thing is that I don't see
it, I mean, if, if Kevin Owens ends up
winning the undisputed championship, I don't see. Having a
long reign at all. I don't see that apparently
has said that he doesn't know how long he's
back for, and he wants to go out in
a blaze of glory, which is what Steve Austin
did, and Muto did that too in 2001. They
both came back from career ending injuries, and they
wrestled for a year or two, like they weren't
injured, and they were like, I don't care about
the consequences and Yeah,
I don't, yeah, yeah, because uh that came to
mind because you see Sammi Zay was also there
and he was champion for a very, very short
while and comparing, for example, what they did in
WWE with the Sami Zay championship reign, we compare
that, comparing that to uh what they did with
Darby Allen in AEW the Darby Allen. RAIN was
much better.
My God, that month of TV was unbelievable. I
was so negative on Darby Allen being world champion,
but when they did the story that he's like,
Look, I'm gonna wrestle every week until my body
breaks. I'm not here for a long time. I'm
here for a good time. I was so wrong
about putting the belt on Darby Island. That was
the best month of wrestling TV in years. So
yeah. Like Sammy is that good. Sammy Zane is
a savant at putting matches together. He was a
E Gennerico, he is a Sammy Zane. I've watched
a couple different shoot interviews where people talk about
Sammy Zane shutting down veterans. He's like, no, stop
talking. I'm, I'm laying out the match, um, because
he's that confident in himself and he is that
good. Uh, SO I like Sammy Zane a lot.
Um, I think. The problem with a lot of
these guys in WWE is the worst thing you
can do is show the writing team that you're
good at comedy, because if you're good at comedy,
they're only gonna make you do comedy, because they
want the comedy stuff.
Yeah, and I, I, I think that when it
comes to Sammy Zan is again, the issue of
him not being big enough, yeah,
size wise. He's so
good. Yeah, yeah, yeah, but, but, but, you know,
WWE, how it treats guys like him, you know,
and, and, you know, when you're appealing to kids,
there is, look, I raved about Obafemi because he's
big and was lit well, right? So I'm not
immune to the wrestlers being big either. I thought,
OK, for this match, I thought Owen's winning was
obviously the right call. I thought even though it
was an 8 minute match, he looked good during
the match, he also dropped some weight, which I
think is very good for his longevity. Um, BECAUSE,
you know, we talk about it in the book,
there are some guys you're fans of as people,
and Kevin Owens, Kevin Steen is one of those
guys that I'm a fan of that person, not
that, not just that wrestler. So when I saw
him come back slimmer, doing his moves, moving quicker,
I was like, OK, this is all a good
sign. Yeah, um, then we get to Baron Corbin
versus Trick Williams.
Yeah,
I do not like Baron Corbin.
Uh, NO, I mean
Iyer was his name on the Indies. I, I
have never seen Baron Corbin and thought there is
money in this guy that people will buy tickets
to watch this guy lose. Um, SO I don't
know why he beat Trick Williams, who I wasn't
a huge fan of Trick Williams from what I
saw, like he seems kind of, uh, green. But
he is obviously a better choice to be champion
than Baron Corbett.
Like, no, I, I, I mean, the, the only
thing I have when it comes to Trick Williams,
and it's not necessarily his fault, but I mean,
come on, there are some. People that compare his
charisma with the Rock, I, I mean, come on,
come on, that, that's totally unrealistic.
The only wrestler I've seen who's similar in charisma
to the Rock. There isn't anyone. He's the most
charismatic wrestler of all time, right? Like, it's almost
a disservice to compare, I think that's part of
the problem with Ricky Saints slash Ricky Starks is
people call him a Timu Rock, and, you know,
that, that is unfortunately what he comes across as,
because next to the Rock, everyone is a Tu
Rock, like, um, to me, uh. But the, in
terms of like the young black wrestler with a
huge upside and charisma, I thought the person that
was like that is, is Swerve was Swerve Scott,
now Swerve Strickland. I thought he had the most
upside and charisma. Um, I also think he's clearly
the most talented in-ring performer of color we have
ever seen. Uh, Swerve is very good. But OK,
yeah, but, but Trick Williams, I, I like Trick
Williams, don't get me wrong, it's just that, I
mean, of course, he's not anywhere near the Rock
in terms of charisma, and I mean, against Baron
Corbin, come on, why did Baron Corbin win this
match?
I mean, Baron Corbin, one of the, I remember
right after I stopped watching, Baron Corbin was the
on-screen scapegoat for wrestling being bad. They tried to
put the heat on the creative being bad on
Baron Corbin, and it's like, I, I just, I
don't know. I, I don't think you, he, he's
never worked for me, he doesn't work for me
now. When I saw him come out, I was
like, are you serious? Why is this guy on
SummerSlam? WHEN there, when there are people on that
roster that could have had that spot, but they
gave it to Baron Corbin, I'm like, oh. So,
you know, it, I did not look forward to
seeing him. Uh,
WHAT about the leather match?
All right, so, um, I wanna say Dave Meltzer
and Brian Alvarez said that is perhaps the worst
ladder match in WWE history. I didn't think it
was bad. But WWE has had a ton of
incredible ladder matches. So it's, you know, so again,
it's, it's not necessarily a bad thing to be
the worst ladder match in WWE history. It's in,
in Louisiana, I used to say I once dated
the prettiest girl in Plaque and Parish, which is
a very rural community, and people used to laugh.
I was like, no, she is really pretty. Um,
BUT you know, it's, it almost comes across like
a backhanded insult. Um, BEING the worst ladder match
in WWE is a pretty good thing to be
actually. So, um, I, Again, so I'm, I'm familiar
with Jade Cargill from AEW. Yeah. I think she
had a major aura downgrade, and that is because
they are not hiding her negatives, which are mostly
in ring. One of my good friends, he's a
sociology professor, Skyler Grimon, uh, he, he said in
10 years, people are gonna still be talking about
how Jade has something, but her in-ring just isn't
there yet. He's like, and it's never gonna get
there. Um, IF it hasn't gotten there by now,
like Brian Danielson coached her. If it hasn't gotten
there by now, it might never be there. Um,
THAT being said, I had never seen Tiffany Stratton
wrestle. I thought she was pretty good. Um,
NO, Tiffany Stratton in ring is pretty, pretty
good, yeah, yeah, yeah. Charlotte Flair, obviously very good.
Um, IF we're talking about what would make the
best matches, Charlotte Flair should have won. Um, I
like Chelsea Green. As a personality, um, so I'm
happy for her winning because I know that on
WWE UnREA, their show that goes into the behind
the scenes, uh, Michael Hayes said she would never
be the main character. So it's nice to see
her being the main character. And I know in
the, the after, after the show, she dedicated her
title win to Michael Hayes. So that was cool.
And, and then Lash Legend was there. And initially,
I got pretty upset that Lash Legend was in
there because it, Lash Legend appears to be just
another Jade Cargill. So it's like, how can Jade
stand out if there's another woman of color powerhouse
in there. Then I saw the match, and I
was like, oh, OK, so Lash Legend is there
to catch women who are doing flips, and you
can't trust Jade to do that. So Lash Legend
was there for the safety of the other performers
in a way that you can't rely on Jade.
So yeah,
yeah, Lash Legend is safer than Jade Cargan. Yeah,
and I noticed she was a very good base
for the high flying, like, anytime someone took a
dangerous bump, she made sure she caught him. And
it's like, OK, I've seen Jade not catch people,
so I understand why they had to do that.
Um, YOU need a big, a big person in
there to be a base for the high flyers
and There were a couple of women in there
who did a lot of flying. And then I
saw Jay drop some women on ladders and stuff.
I'm like, OK, yeah, she's, she's kind of sloppy.
Um, IT is what it is.
Yeah, but, but, but look, still, even with the
in-ring negatives, uh, look, I think I, I, I
think that Jade Cargill should have won. I mean,
I, I'm just going to say it. I,
I gotta say like Jade, Jade looks wise is
wonderful. Like when she. Walks out. She is very
much the, if you see her at an airport,
you look twice or 3 times because she is
that striking. She's beautiful. She's athletic. She has massive
amounts of charisma. It's just the in ring isn't
there. I
mean, there's no one like, like her in, right?
She does stand out, and you need people that
stand out like that. I just, I just wish
she was a little bit more polished in the
ring. But
yeah, but, but, but look, compared to the others,
I mean, Charlotte Fleur. She's already a 14 time
champion. I don't want her to be champion anytime
soon. Um,
YEAH, is Ashley Flair, because she said in interviews
that it's that she doesn't like that the women
are being criticized for aging in a way that
men Main Eventters aren't, and she's absolutely right. She
does not look like someone who is 40 years
old or late 30s or early 40s. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. She still looks like a champion, just like
her dad, and if they're going to downgrade her.
Because of her age, she absolutely should jump just
like I think Bailey is about to jump, and
I think that's the best thing Bailey could do.
Um, I think Bailey is looking at her best
friend Mercedes getting 25 minute matches and has to
be a little bit jealous of that. Um, I
would be if, you know, if I was as
a theater artist, if I saw someone getting all
these opportunities that I'm not, I would want to
jump ship too. So, so I think Charlotte probably
needs to jump,
uh, and then, and then Tiffany Stratton, I mean,
she's great, but she She was a champion just
last year and yeah, world champion just last year,
and now she's US champion, so I don't think
she should hold both championships
and I don't like double champions. I think
and and then Lash Legend, she's good, but she's
still not there yet, yeah, and she's paired up
with Naya Jackson. I think that if she was
going to be women's champion, she should. First start
their her singles career, I guess.
So I'm not a fan of Naya Jack's. I
never have been. I, I'm just, it, it, I've
never liked her in ring. Very pretty woman. Um,
OBVIOUSLY, I don't want people to think I'm trashing
her because she, she's a bigger girl. She's beautiful,
but I just don't like her in ring. Like
when she wrestles, I get bored. Um, BUT that's
another person, if you're related to the Rock, you
get lots of chances, uh, in wrestling to make
it, and I wanna say Naya Jackson is one
of the Rock's cousins. Um, I did, so the
last thing I want to say about the women's
ladder match, people were so happy that Chelsea Green
won. And that was really cool to see. Like,
it was very obvious that they went with the
crowd on this. Like they, they will, will Chelsea
Green have the best matches coming out of this?
Probably not, but like people were genuinely happy, and
it's nice to give people what they want. OK,
let's talk about human monies on a pole match,
Danhausen versus Dominic.
Oh, OK, so look, the thing is, I find
Vanhausen to be funny. I mean, I, I like
his sort of sketches slash promos. I like that,
but I don't think that they should be doing
Dominic Mysterio this dirty. I mean, come
on. I think Dominic. Like we said earlier, is
a, is one of the best natural heels I've
ever seen. And apparently in AAA, he's being booked
as like a, a serious wrestler, and he, he's
not booked like that in WWE. Um, I like
him from what I saw. I thought, I don't
know, Michael Cole called Dan, no, someone called Dan
Han on commentary a pale theater kid, and as
a, a formerly pale theater kid, you know, it's
not an insult, um. To me, I don't care
for Danhausen. Um, I, I believe the, the comment
I wrote is, I'm looking at my phone, sorry,
Danhausen to me is the face of wrestling and
shittification. Um, HE is, he's, it's very obvious they
are bleeding every bit of money they can get
out of his merch sales out of him. They're
going to shove him down your throat until you're
sick of him.
But, but, but, but you know what, I'm going
to tell you something because I, I have one
very specific perspective on this. I, I mean, it's
not my own perspective, but I got my parents
into wrestling, and they are, and they are Portuguese,
and they don't speak a word of it. English,
so they
likenhausen,
but they still, but they still watch the wrestling,
and I mean, they like Vanhausen because for particularly
for people who do not speak English. I mean,
Danhausen is, is funny.
The physical humor is something that translates. So I
talk about that in my, my dissertation, um, when
we talk about, is it, I think it's erotetic
narratives, but one of the reasons wrestling is so
beloved. Worldwide is that it does not presuppose fluency
in English. Um, AND because of that, and that's
why Marvel movies are so big, uh, the philosopher
Noel Carroll talks about that in philo in the
ontology of mass art, which is one of my
favorite works of aesthetics of the last 30 years.
And he says like, he doesn't talk about wrestling
and, in particularly, he talks about movies and horror
and things like that, but anything that can transcend
the assumption of. Literacy is going to be more
widely appreciated, and that's integral to his concept of
mass art. And I think wrestling absolutely fits that.
Um, AND to his credit, he does too. He
responds to some of his critics in, uh, the
Journal of Aesthetics and Art Criticism when they're like,
according to Noel Carroll, WWE SmackDown would be art.
And he wrote in his response, well, I guess
so. He's like, I don't watch it, but if
it's, it's, it's what you described, it probably is.
It probably is a good example of mass art.
So I can see why Dan Han is for
people. The thing I thought is like, um, he's
probably like Jerry Lewis, uh, very, he'd be very
big in France. And, um, if you like physical
humor, that that you don't require a translation for
that. Um, I personally got sick of Dan Han
in AEW. So, you know, him going to WWE,
I know he's friends with CM Punk, and, and
they're making a lot of money off of him,
and I'm very happy that he gets to live
this life. I'm, I'm a fan of him as
a person. Uh, I'm just watching him wrestle his,
that is not the draw for me. Um,
YEAH, I mean, I mean, again, the, the, the
thing that really bothered me the most about this
is them putting Dominic Mysterio in the mix. I
mean, I, he doesn't deserve to be treated like
that.
Anyone put in the ring with Danhausen is going
to be a joke, um, is the problem, and
there are people that can withstand being a joke,
and typically those are people that you don't think
can make money. And I think Dominic Mysterio can
make money. Um, THERE'S a saying in wrestling, I
think Jim Cornett is the one who quoted it
first in a shoot interview. He says, funny isn't
money. As a rule, comedy can work on the
card, but it can't work as the main event
of the card. So, anyone you put in a
comedy situation is being intentionally put in a position
where they cannot draw money. And for Dominic Mysterio,
I think he could make money. Um, I think
that I don't know what his ceiling is, but
it is higher than it currently is in WWE.
Um, I think that A lot like his, uh,
I was gonna say a lot like his dad,
and storyline, for people that don't know, his biological
father is Eddie Guerrero. Um, THAT was a storyline
that they did when Dominic was a was a
very young child. Uh, I called it the Dominic
Mysterio on a pole match where the winner gets
custody of Dominic between Rey Mysterio and Eddie Guerrero.
But the great thing about a young Eddie Guerrero
is when he walked out, and I, I would
teach wrestling in my theater classes. I would show
them Rey Mysterio versus Eddie Guerrero from Halloween Havoc
1997. And the moment Eddie Guerrero walks out, you
know, he's the bad guy. And Dominic Mysterio has
that same quality. I don't think I could ever
cheer for him. Um, BUT there is a lot
of value in having someone that when they walk
out, you immediately know you need to boo. There's
that's appropriate for wrestling, and I think that's, that's
really good. So I'm with you, Dominic. He deserved
better, at least they didn't pin him, right? Like
it's a human human monies on a pole match,
so Danhausen won by grabbing the human monies off
the pole, so Dominic did not get pinned, he
just got beat up by little people, um, and
then, then his stablemate from Judgment Day came out
who Is it much bigger than the little people
in terms of heights? Yeah,
yeah, JD McDonough, I mean the entire judgment, they
think, I mean they should have ended it long
ago. I mean, also because at this point originally
it was. Edge, Damien Priest, Finn Beller and Rhea
Ripley, and they were all badasses, and Judgment Day
is a very good name for a group with
those people, but with the goofy guys that we
have now in judgment, oh come on, come on,
it, I don't, it doesn't make sense anymore.
I like uh. I, I like the concept of
Judgment Day. I haven't seen the newest incarnation. I
am familiar with the Edge version just from listening
to reviews of shows, and it sounds like it
was initially a group of people that was very
serious, and now it sounds like it's a group
of people that is more there for the entertainment
aspects of the show.
Yeah, yeah, and, and, and because of that, the
name Judgment Day doesn't even make sense anymore. So
yeah,
yeah. So let's talk Chad Gable versus Penta. Yeah.
I thought that match could have been the best
on the show, if it had been 5 to
7 minutes longer. I thought it was very good
as it was, but it felt like right when
they were really cooking, they had to go to
the finish, um, and yeah,
because they are both great in ring performers. I
mean, in ring they're great.
When they said on commentary that Chad Gable has
never held a singles title in WWE, I was
like, what an indictment of WWE to have someone
that's this caliber of wrestler.
Uh, YEAH, and do, and do you know what
the funniest thing here is that. I think that
they were forced to push, to give a push
to Chad Gable just because of the incredible match
match he
had
as as uh El Grande Americano, the original against,
uh, oh my God, what's the, the original name
of the guy, he was Tiffany Stratton's boyfriend, er
Ilya Dragov. No, no, it's
not Ilya Dragonov, it's, he was together with he
was together with Gunter. Yeah, Ludwig, yeah, I mean
that match was awesome, but it was put together
by the Undertaker.
Yeah, so, I mean, people can say what they
want about the Undertaker, but his ability to put
together a big match is really impressive. Um, I
think the problem with Undertaker is Undertaker came in
and got injured very young. He'd been talking about
retiring due to injuries starting in 1997. Like that's
how long Undertaker was injured, and he then, then
he had the career renaissance on SmackDown with Kurt
Angle. That was when I was really passionate about
watching. And uh it was really fun. But yeah,
once he's in there with good guys and not
put in there with, you know, kind of crappy
guys like Giant Gonzalez and uh all the, all
the people in the 90s
King Kong Bundy,
he's got the psychological aspects of wrestling down pat.
He understands it. Yeah. So, you know, Chad Gable's
great, um, Penta, I loved an AEW. I thought
it was time for him to jump, um. When
he jumped, and I think that he fits in
with WWE much better than Ray Phoenix does. I
think he, I think Penta should have jumped, and
Ray Phoenix probably should have stayed in AEW, um,
and they'd both be about where they should be,
cause Ray Phoenix had a lot of upside as
a main eventor or high flyer in AEW that,
but WWE doesn't value that, but Penta's character work
is so good. And so like, it comes across
in a big stadium. Also, Pina's daughter wants to
be a wrestler, and I think going to WWE
gives her an in with the Performance Center, which
is the best place to train her. So for
Penta's career and his family, it made a lot
of sense for him to jump, um, but, you
know, like Pina wanted to be a single star,
um, and Ray Phoenix is now talking about wanting
to get their tag team back together because Ray
Phoenix is not on TV. So I, I get
that, um, but yeah, I thought that was a,
I thought that was a pretty good match. It
would have been better if it was longer. It's
the only, probably the only match that I would
say that about on SummerSlams tonight.
Yeah, and I agree with you. I think if
it was 78 minutes longer, it would have probably
been the best match. Of the entire, the entire
two nights.
Yeah, I feel like if they'd have given more
time to it, you really could have allowed them
to sell a bit more and, um, you know,
because they were, they were actually going too fast.
It's the only match I would say that about
because they knew they only had 11 minutes. They
had to get all their stuff in. And if
they'd had just a little bit of room to
breathe, I think by the end that could have
been something. Um, WELL, we're on the main event,
Seth Rollins versus Roman Reigns, and I wanna say,
OK, so the last time I saw Roman Reigns,
he was being shoved down our throats as the
top guy, despite the crowd rejecting it. Yeah, he
comes out looking like the top guy and the
crowd accepts him, so that's, that's really good that,
that's, yeah,
you know, I'm going to say fortunately they treated
Obafemi the opposite way, and the people love him
because they could have done the same thing with
Obafemi and just tried to push him down people's
throats.
That's the difference between Vince McMahon and Paul Leveck
as a, as a creative writer, I guess, is
that he's not going to. You know, shut, he's
gonna let the guy get over organically before risking
the crowd preemptively rejecting him like they did with
Roman, cause that could have gone really bad. It
was bad, I think it was bad for Roman's
career that he had to fight against the crowd
because he was pushed too hard too soon, um,
but he comes out here looking amazing, like he
He, his entrance was probably my favorite of all
the nights, cause it was kind of simple. It
was just a big dude coming out, being shown
to advantage, and I'm like, oh, this guy is
a big deal. This guy, this guy is like,
clearly the champion, he's who I'm supposed to care
about. I assumed he was the baby face, that
was wrong. Um, AND then Seth Rollins, you know,
when Seth Rollins came out, what did I write?
Um, Seth Rollins' outfit is ugly. Um, IT, it
looks like if you asked a seven year old
child to draw with a pack of crayons, an
entrance outfit for a wrestler, um, and it looks
like that the that the costumer took that drawing
and made it. He was just, it was like
the worst of John Cena with the primary colors,
but dressed in a way that no one could
take seriously. So I assumed he was the heel,
because I was like, no babyface would dress like
that. Um, I was wrong, it turns out. But,
um, a thing I noticed at the pre, at
the pre-match, um, They used a lot of the
camera angles that they use in the WWE video
games, and I don't know if that's an instance
of the show imitating the game or the game
imitating the show. But uh, for that match, maybe
my rural broadband was really good, but it was
in ultra high def. It almost looked like a
video game in terms of the, the resolution, it
was gorgeous. So I'm watching and I'm like, the,
the line between the video game simulation and the
product in WWE is very narrow now, in a,
in a way that I think is unprecedented. Um.
I also, what did I say? Um, I don't
like them having a full conversation mid-match. Um, I
also, I watched the angle with John Cogburn, uh,
12 years ago that started that match. John came
over to my house that I was in grad
school. School and John uh needed a night away
from, from the fam, so he wanted a boys'
night. So we, he came over to my house,
we watched the angle, and it was like, cool.
So I didn't have a nostalgia for that angle
the way a lot of people do, but I,
I was also much older than a lot of
people were when that angle happened. So I get
that. Um, BY the end of the match, the
finisher reversal sequences, I thought were really good. Um,
I did think when Rollins did the slow walk
to get the chair, it was too slow, it
was like, yeah, and, and, and Michael Cole telling
me, he's going to get the chair, just like
12 years ago that started this whole thing. It's,
I'm, maybe a new fan would need to know
that, but I actually think if you don't say
everything. Um, YOU can really allow the moment to
speak for itself. Um, BUT the last thing I
wrote on my phone is, who is the good
guy in this match? Because at the end, I
realized I had no clue. Yeah, and that's OK.
I don't know, this was, this was fun. What
did you think of the match?
Uh, I, I mean, it was, it was a,
a good match, I guess that the storyline was
there as well. It's just that. I mean, even
when compared to the other big championship match which
was called the Rhodes versus Siampan, I mean, I
think. I preferred Goldie Rhodes versus Sim Pancono.
I think I preferred Rains and Rollins, um, but,
but I liked both matches, so it's not, that's
not me saying one is bad and one was
good. It was just like, I think I liked
Rollins reigns better.
And then again, the other thing that you mentioned
earlier, uh, I, I mean, I, I really get
pissed. Of when they don't want to mention other
wrestlers like in that case, John Moxley slash Dean
Ambrose because that that last moment where they put
their fists together, I mean they could have mentioned
it
because they did it, you saw they did it
like kind of like this and the third fist
was. Not there. And that to me was powerful.
And they did not mention it. And I was
like, oh, OK, cool. So it's like, it's, it's
almost like, to me, subtlety and wrestling needs to
be kind of like an Easter egg in a
video or a movie or something like that, where
there are messages for the people that are deeply
invested in the fandom. That aren't apparent to people
that aren't, but the product is enjoyable to both.
And I know that's a big thing with Marvel
movies and things like that. I think wrestling could
use more stuff like that, where, you know, you,
you have the, the, the references that are there
for the diehards, but the product still works for
the people that are watching live. And I think
the WWE model, they're So worried people are going
to miss the nuance. They don't have subtext, they
just have text. Anything that's subtextual has to be
stated by an announcer to confirm that the audience
is reacting correctly. And I get that that's what
they're going for. I just don't care for that
part of the production. But if you're, if you're
appealing to kids that don't have a Sense of
history. I understand why that's necessary. But with the
WWE network on ES is it ESPN? I, I
don't know. Y'all get it on Netflix because y'all
are international. I had to sign up for ESPN,
uh, streaming for 30 bucks to get it in
the United States, uh, which is how much I
love the dissenter, right, that I, I spent money
to do the podcast on my own, my own
hard earned money. And, uh, you know, it, it
was cool. Um, I, I appreciate that I'm watching
wrestling differently than the people they're targeting just because
I'm 45, and I've been watching for 33 years.
So, you know, that, that to me, my fandom
is gonna be different than their fandom, just like
the, the thing I said about how not having
nostalgia for the, the angle that started the Shield
breakup. I remember it, but I was a pretty
jaded fan by that point, and And I thought
the standout member of the Shield was Dean Ambrose,
not Roman Reigns and not Seth Rollins. So to
me, it, it felt like the wrong guy turned,
uh, but, you know, it is, it is what
it is, and I get that they're trying to
appeal to kids and that they're almost like the,
they want that cycle of kids watching wrestling to
continue, and because those kids don't have a sense
of history about it yet. They have to make
the history relevant in the present. So I do,
I do get that. It's just a stylistic thing
that I don't prefer. How do you feel about
the, the, the text versus subtext?
Uh, YEAH, I, I, I mean, the, the thing
is, uh, I have, uh, of course, I, I
don't come at wrestling, uh, analyzing it the same
way that you do because I don't, I don't
have the same, uh, intellectual tools that you have.
I mean, I'm just, uh, um, an intellectual guy
with an interest in wrestling, and I'm more, I,
I'm more, I'm more from the social sciences than,
uh
you're what Ramsci
would call
an organic intellectual.
But, but, but, but I mean, I, I understand
why WWE does some, uh, some of the things
the way they do, but I mean, the main
criticisms I have of WWE, we have already laid
them out here during our conversation today, but, so,
but that's the perspective of a longtime fan who,
who watched, I mean, in retrospect, the attitude era,
and I was, I became a fan during the
Ruthless aggression era and all I like Ruthless aggression
a lot, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, and I mean
it's just that. Some things you can't avoid making
comparisons and um back then they were just better.
Well, and I'm looking forward to talking about AEW
all in with John if John can make it,
because John does not watch AEW regularly, so he'll
be the me, um, pointing out the stuff that
doesn't make sense, and I'm probably gonna complain about
how long the show is. Like, I'm just a
spoiler. AW shows are awesome, but, but they're long,
and I'm very,
yeah, yeah, that's, that's one thing that 11 criticism
that I have. I'm, I, I mean, it's, it's
a, it's not too much, but it's a bit
too much,
you
know.
Yeah, it, it, I mean, it's almost like complaining
like, oh my God, don't give me $1000 like,
don't give me all this great wrestling. So I
appreciate that we get all the great wrestling, but
I had to tell my wife, and, and, and
so I also stream about D&D with a friend
of mine who's a voice actor and professional dungeon
master. So I had to tell him like, dude,
we stream on Sunday nights, I'm like, the night
of AEW all in, I am going to be
fried. Like, even though the show is happening in
the middle of the day, uh, Central Standard Time,
it's gonna be 6 hours of locking in, and
I'm gonna be fried afterwards because it's just. That's
how the pace of that show is. Even when
I was at last year's All In Live, uh,
my wife and I, we drove back home after
the show. It was a 4 hour drive. We
were wrecked. Like we, we were scared. I had
to take over driving the last 20 minutes because
she was about to fall asleep at the wheel.
We were so exhausted. And that's just because when
you've got a show that long, and the, the
booking philosophy, so, an overall comment about, about the
way WWE promotes shows is they make sure the
show peaks at the main event, and the way
they do that is, they don't allow other matches
to be as good as the featured match is
going to be. Which is one philosophy of promoting.
So frequently there'll be a good match, then there'll
be a match that takes you down a bit,
then there'll be a good match, then they'll kind
of let you rest. Then there's the bathroom break,
the match that no one cares about, blah, blah,
blah. AEW doesn't do that. They start off and
everyone is trying to have the best match you've
ever seen on the show. And while it's wonderful,
it can be exhausting because your adrenaline is gonna
crash at some point during it. I used to,
uh, when I saw it chapter 2, which I
don't know if you're a horror movie fan. I'm
a huge horror movie fan. I thought the It
movies were great, but the second It movie had
so many jump scares, my adrenaline was done by
the end of the movie. I jumped scared 30+
times, and just my body physically couldn't handle it.
And sometimes with those 6 hour shows, that's how
it is. If you're up for every match, like,
Your body physically, like, we have to understand, and
I'm a theater person, so we talk about this,
Audiences are people, audiences have bodies. There are bodily
functions that need to happen. There are like physical
changes that go on when you watch a show.
There are group dynamics, there's yada yada yada. So,
you know, AEW as good as as it is,
they do not pay attention to the biological needs
of their fans, like, they do not give us
bathroom breaks. Uh, THEY don't do any of that.
So by the end, you're gonna be dead tired.
Yeah, yeah, no, but, but look, uh, I have
to say, and also because we have to wrap
up our conversation, I have to say that, uh,
for WWE standards nowadays, uh, SummerSlam was really a
good pay per view.
I thought, um, you know, it, it, it really,
if I had seen that pay per view when
I was 12. That was significantly better than the
pay per views of the 90s, until, even including
the attitude era, honestly, the attitude era would typically
have good main events, but the undercard wouldn't be
that hot. But this show was very, like, if
you only watch WWE or mainstream wrestling, it's excellent.
Um, IF you watch other promotions, and I've seen
other ways of promoting wrestling, you can have quibbles
with it, but if, if you're just a WWE
fan, you are very well served by that pay
per view. And it was, it was fun, um,
it was, it was fun. It was just, you
know, uh, two nights of SummerSlam is a lot.
Uh, IT was like watching one AEW show, so.
Yeah, but, but about the undercard from the attitude
era, I have to say that the matches, the
in-ring usually wasn't good, but the characters were still
awesome.
So it was more like a variety show. Um,
IT was kind of like hee-haw, if, if you're
familiar with the, the genre of hee-haw, it was
a. A country show in the 80s and early
90s on, on basic cable and it was like
a variety show. Um AND sometimes you'd get one
thing, sometimes you'd get skits, sometimes you'd get songs.
That's
how, but the thing is back then, even the
undercard characters were great, yeah.
I mean, the gang, they did gang warfare a
lot with the, the bikers versus the uh black
nationalists versus the Latino factions. And yeah, that was,
I mean, that looking back, it was problematic, um,
but it was also very fun TV where you
had groups fighting each other all the time. You
had gold dust showing up being weird. Um, YOU,
you, there was something for everybody back then. And
I, I do think. The good thing about SummerSlam
is there was something for everybody on those two
nights, but I would have liked a comedy match
on the first night as well. Um, I'd have
liked something that was more fun, uh, because although
the Danhausen stuff wasn't for me. Uh, IT does
serve a purpose on the card. It, if you
don't like that kind of thing, you can go
to the bathroom. If you do like that kind
of thing, it, it's sort of like you don't
have to get so involved in the match. You
can kind of just calm down, rest, be entertained,
and, uh, be ready for the next intense moment.
So for me, you know, I would have liked
to have seen a little bit more comedy on
night one. But you know, it was fun. I
had a good time.
Yeah, OK, so maybe let's wrap up the interview.
We've been here for almost 2 hours here, and
I hope to be able to review all AEW
all in in early September, hopefully, hopefully, hopefully with
John Cockburn joining us and Maybe then we will
have enough time for me to uh talk about
my, uh, evil genius plan for Tessa Blanchard in
WWE.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, you told me about that
before we started. That sounds really good. I will
exert social pressure on John to see if I
could convince him to do all in. Um, WE'LL,
we'll try to brace himself and get him ready
for it so he can lock in. Um, BUT
hopefully it'll be the three of us again. This
was, this was a lot of fun. Thank you
so much for inviting me on. I loved it.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herzognun, Mahel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolatti, Gabriel P Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannaertner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas Stinnik,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al Nick
Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.